Speaker 1: All right, let's have a little
fun here, a unit before we get to some
serious stuff. You know that one of my favorite
things, if you watch my live streams is when
Donald Trump has technical problems with
his audio. And it actually happens a lot.
Speaker 2: And I spreadable all these
people don't know what the hell. Let no
further scream that his days are numbered.
Trump. This is a growth and prosperity
deal that included the largest
agricultural resource of our
farm product. Okay. But I think, Eric, they're not
like they lived up. I used to check it every week.
Are they buying? Are they buying?
Speaker 1: Okay. So yesterday,
apparently in the middle of thinking he's very
close to getting arrested, Donald Trump called
in to some pastors for Trump show. I don't
even know how he gets booked on this stuff,
to be totally honest. And it's all really weird.
And about 50 seconds in when they ask him for a
prayer call. The audio just goes completely
crazy. And then Trump claims that the radical
left hacked him. It's. Let's just listen.
Speaker 3: And we are ready to introduce the
president of the United States.
Speaker 1: By the way, the the
president thought the president of the
United States is Joe Biden, isn't it?
Speaker 3: Donald J. Trump is coming on live with
us the 45th and going to be the 47th president of
the United States of America that President
trump. Welcome to pastors for trump. National
prayer call for you. How are you doing, sir?
Speaker 2: I'm doing well. Jackson Appreciate
it. And it's an honor to be
with you. And I just had a
great General Flynn and my friend Rogers.
Speaker 1: And so we already have the Echo,
but this is nothing compared to what happens.
Speaker 2: I was very honored to give them
full card because they were treated horribly by
government, these radical left lunatics. And I am
so glad they're almost as clean as you are right
now. JACKSON That's a special category, okay. But
there are two terrific people that really suffered
greatly at the hands of crazy people. So this was
my my great honor and play. Thank you very much
for the great job you've done. And Kristin Davis,
we appreciate it very much. Ceremony.
Speaker 4: President Trump, I wanted to tell you,
I was in my what my wife and I were attending
the NCAA wrestling event in Tulsa, Oklahoma,
and we could see you. And all I could say is that
my wife and I, Pastor Jackson, everybody out there
is praying for you. And I think a lot of people
are looking for a specific pastor. What is the
prayer that you would like for the thousands of
pastors who are tuning in right now? What are the
specific prayer request you have tonight, sir?
Speaker 1:
Yeah. Hmm.
This is all still live, remember?
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Speaker 1:
That's Trump saying they can't hear that.
Somebody is working on something.
Very, very important stuff here. Some people
thought maybe Trump got arrested and that's
why he went quiet. But that was seemingly
not the case. But more Trump whispering.
One of the hosts gives a thumbs up.
And they're getting very, very
close here to fixing the audio.
It's not even really clear what the problem is,
because you can hear Trump kind of breathing in
the background, strangely enough. They may not
have prayed hard enough for the audio anyway.
Everybody's getting upset now. Okay.
Can you imagine waiting all day for
your interview with Trump? And then
this happens.
Speaker 2:
Okay. I guess we have a little phone
miscommunication. And I think what
happened is the radical left, we can hear how the
radical left was working on the phone. There's
no question about it. But I think you heard
what I said previously. Is that right, fellas?
Hello?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Anyway, that. That's basically
enough. Now, there were people. There were people
who wrote to me and said the reason this happened
is because Trump doesn't like to answer religious
questions. Right. Remember this? You mentioned
the Bible. You've been talking about how it's.
Speaker 5: Your favorite book. And you said,
I think last night in Iowa. Some people are
surprised that you say that. I'm wondering
what one or two of your most favorite
Bible verses are. And I wouldn't want to
get into it because to me, that's very personal.
Speaker 2: You know, when I talk about the Bible,
it's very personal. So I don't want to
get into verses I don't want to get into.
Speaker 5: It means a lot to you
that you think about or say the.
Speaker 2: Bible means a lot
to me, but I don't want to get.
Speaker 1: Into specifics. All right. So
anyway, I actually don't think that's what
happened. I think that was genuine trouble
and I loved absolutely every second of it.